hey what's going on it's Bilborough and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday November 12 2004 a teen I
still haven't fixed this stupid
microphone how are you how's it going
how's it going in your world I know
everybody who hates the Patriots is is
is happy today
Jesus Christ what a bunch of babies man
I've never seen a [ __ ] team well
maybe not true I guess we used to
[ __ ] hate the Yankees like that but
it's just like every time we lose a
[ __ ] game it's like no I mean how
many [ __ ] times one of these times
it's gonna be the end sure Brady's
[ __ ] 41 years old all these [ __ ]
jerk-offs talking [ __ ] and by the way
Dion Lewis that were really disappointed
with that they asked him was it personal
he said is it personal he said hell yeah
it's personal that's what happens when
you go cheap you get your ass kicked
it's like dude this isn't something new
this this was going on way before when
you would like [ __ ] eight years old
this is the way they ran the team and
you went in then you got yourself a
ringer - what's the problem
Jesus Christ yeah this is what happens
when you go cheap you lose a game in
November these guys just acted like they
just knocked us out of the [ __ ]
playoffs however I couldn't help but
think when I did not watch one second in
that game yesterday sorry I was flying
back from Chicago I watched some
highlights of it and I hadn't seen my
kiddo in like a week so you know
obviously I'm not going to come home and
sit down a bunch of [ __ ] football
game I do have it on tape I am gonna
[ __ ] watch it or whatever what do you
think whatever you kids call it I do I
have it on the cloud yeah it just
sounded like you know they were the
better team they [ __ ] came in they
were ready to go we weren't and we got
behind early and
with the game you know I don't want to
be seven and three I don't know what the
[ __ ] everybody is you know this guy just
goes it's just just a blip on the radar
as I said we're playing 700 ball that's
how high the [ __ ] standard is so
anyways in evidently I think the Titans
just won a [ __ ] championship
according to Dion Lewis you know I don't
get it I love that guy but like I was
you know you know what I mean like I
don't understand why people say [ __ ]
like that in November if you learned
anything in New England you know that
November you didn't win anything you won
a game that's it congratulations I got
to tell you though I couldn't help but
think about that lunatic that I saw in
that sports bar in New York City a few
weeks ago when the Patriots are playing
the Chiefs and now that guy was just
yelling going [ __ ] you know this is
it this is how it is now you guys are
over looking around the bar it's over
right
I I can't imagine I was psyched he was
yesterday when the Patriots lost and the
Chiefs won cuz now I believe the Chiefs
have a two-game lead despite head to
head you know we won the game but like
that's a really good look for them if we
got to try to beat them again in Kansas
City will the Chiefs finally push their
way through I gotta be honest see if the
Chiefs do get through if they do get
past us if we can actually make it there
if I can [ __ ] hear myself and this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] microphone if they
do beat us or whatever that that will be
the team that I root for in the
Superbowl because Jesus Christ they
haven't wanted since like [ __ ] Bart
Starr was in the league I think he might
have just retired by the way the last
great number 15 at quarterback Bart
Starr no offense - Neal Lomax anyways
what else I am done for the year people
with road dates other than this little
trip I have to take to New York to
promote f is for family season 3 which
comes out November
Netflix I'm in town and I ain't doing
[ __ ] [ __ ] except hanging out with my
daughter you know what I can't we are
relative ours got a gutter up one of
those electric [ __ ] cars you know
they can sit in I came home and I put
that thing together it was [ __ ]
hilarious
she got on the thing she didn't get it
and took her a couple times just pushing
the button and then she just she
actually took her finger off the button
laughed and clapped her hands like this
is this [ __ ]
so you know cuz one of my big days is a
dad coming up I don't know maybe and
depending on how tall she is sometimes
when she's around 11 or 12 is I'm gonna
teach her how to drive my truck which
shifts three on the column you know
which no [ __ ] kid you know for the
most part knows how to drive a stick
anymore forget about one on the column
so I think it'd be pretty badass if I
teach her how to do that and that's
stuff that when I was a kid my dad used
to do that he used to take us down to
the South Shore Plaza when I was like 12
years old 11 and 12 and I go down there
in a 1978 Chevy Chevette 4-speed
transmission and that was back when the
the mall was closed on Sunday because
everybody you know allegedly was going
to church and on the seventh day you
know God rested and and you know blah
blah blah blah blah all that [ __ ] so you
know you couldn't sell any liquor
you couldn't sell any booze you couldn't
be open like grocery stores would be
open but that was basically it and they
had like Sunday hours you know so we
used to go down there in the empty
parking lot and he taught all his kids
how to drive down there we've learned on
a stick shift and I remember when I went
to go get my driver's license I took it
on a stick I think it was that car no we
would have got rid of it by that no no
no that's right we still had it
we still had it
nineteen eighty-four only be six years
old even though a [ __ ] tree fell on
it we got a fixed yeah I went down I
took in I remember the guy made me park
on a hill you know doing that [ __ ] I got
a [ __ ]
alright here we go just don't stall out
here and then you're gonna be fine
you're gonna be fine it's one of the few
tests that I passed during those years
everything else everything else that I
guess really [ __ ] matter that would
have led to a nicer car I failed but
then I started doing comedy and all boy
everything happened for me I got to play
at the Chicago theater everybody for for
incredible shows I want to thank
everybody that came out we had such a
great time when we were there we didn't
make it to the liar's club so you can
tell it but fighting off a cold and it's
just the last time I went to the liar's
club man I was there till like 4:00 in
the [ __ ] morning and didn't wake up
till 5:00 in the afternoon and then did
a show at the Chicago theater I felt
like it was breakfast time I'd literally
just had eggs and walked on stage and
these poor people have been working all
[ __ ] day and I came out there like
this [ __ ] bum still a good show
though because I'm a pro [ __ ] with
you anyways we ate at this place new
place we went to in Chicago's plays
Gibson's we got a steak creamed spinach
was [ __ ] unbelievable and then in the
end I got to get the name of this
[ __ ] thing that these guys said they
go do you want dessert and you know when
you go out and get a steak you know if
you get like the filet mignon and it's a
smart way to go but there's no flavor
and it's really bland they was gonna
have all these dipping sauces with it so
I got some bone-in ribeye I hate that
thing like [ __ ] Fred Flintstone so
now I'm sitting there even though we
didn't get potatoes or anything I'm
still I'm [ __ ] leaning I ate the
whole thing I should have cut it in half
I didn't I'm [ __ ] leading and these
guys come over and they were like hey
you want dessert and we're like no no no
we're good were good they're like no no
so some of the waiters went to the show
last night they want to bring you over
they want to bring you over a [ __ ]
desert right
trying to find this Gibson's menu
Chicago hang on a second I got a I have
to upload a [ __ ] picture of this
thing they brought this goddamn piece of
cake
this [ __ ] piece of cake over I swear
to god it was like it was like a whole
cake something like banana dreamboat
when I saw the menu I was saying to my
somebody I forget who I said I love you
20 bucks if you just [ __ ] order this
just because I want to hear you say it
out loud
Gibson's menu all right what is it
called here hang on hang on all right
here's the menu what do we got here the
meaning of life cake that wasn't it
pumpkin pie banana cream pie
oh yeah no [ __ ] have it was something
like banana dreamboat I know what it was
but it was also was Versys birthday yeah
we took him out to breakfast right and
we ended up getting him there we go it's
his birthday so it was breakfast and
they brought over like some [ __ ] one
of those chocolate whipped cream [ __ ]
waffles or whatever and we sang happy
birthday to him is loud as humanly
possible in the thing just getting right
in his face and I was actually joking
with fros years ago you know what I go
that's why guys are funny because if we
were women that actually would have been
sincere he was just sitting there
[ __ ] embarrassed to [ __ ] it was such
a great time so anyways I'll be honest
with you I really don't have a lot to
[ __ ] talk about I've been just
fighting off this goddamn cold oh I know
what I can talk about so when I was in
when I was in Chicago you know I told my
travel agent I go booked me booked me in
a nice hotel close to the [ __ ] the
venue now I'm a fancy man at this point
so I don't even handle ending that [ __ ]
I finally learned how to delegate stuff
because I was doing my whole career I
was like [ __ ] Chuck Berry the way
he'd drive up to the
you in his own car with his [ __ ]
guitar in the backseat that's what I was
doing you know which adds a ton of
[ __ ] responsibility and [ __ ] because
then you got to tell your openers well
where the hotel is you got to go in you
got to check out I never had a [ __ ]
tour manager never did that [ __ ] because
you know I'm an antisocial son of a
[ __ ] and all I'm thinking is this is
just gonna be another [ __ ] guy I have
to talk to and bla bla bla bla bla and
I'm just gonna be that down-to-earth
[ __ ] guy who just [ __ ] blah blah
blah you know just comes walking in well
that's what I did and guess what
now I'm getting text messages from
people who work at [ __ ] Avis who I
rented a car
you know [ __ ] eight years stupid
stupid [ __ ] move that's what being
down-to-earth gets you it's a bunch of
people [ __ ] calling you up you know
that you had a two-second interaction
with alright so if you learn anything on
this podcast alright as you move up the
ladder it's very important to forget
where you came from
alright and what you want to do is treat
people who you feel your ego tells you
are not at your level you want to treat
them less than okay no but there is
there is a certain level you know well
you have to kind of dial it back like I
went out and did a [ __ ]
meet-and-greet you know one time when I
was in Reno this guy goes take a picture
with my wife and I go find and he
reaches in his jacket to [ __ ] take
out a camera and a nine-millimeter fell
on the [ __ ] ground and I pointed at
the gun and went oh [ __ ] and watched him
pick it back up again like a [ __ ] I
should have kicked it I should have done
some sort of Steven Seagal move but you
know that's I mean I didn't grow up
around guns I was just like oh I think
you dropped something sir fortunately it
was an off-duty cop although he ran out
of there because it was a Native
American reservation they want we were
on their land and you're not allowed to
bring a a weapon in there
probably especially as a white man
considering what happened the first time
around they probably don't want [ __ ]
white people coming in with guns anymore
right so there was that there was
another time I had a group of people
followed me home from the venue and I
got out of the car and there was the hey
Bill as I got out and I was just like oh
[ __ ] what's gonna happen you know a
little mini heart attack are you gonna
kill me
oh you just want a picture right so
anyways I'm one of those people I know
what airline I'm flying as I drive to
the airport I do that [ __ ] right so
we're on our way to Chicago like the
night before so I asked my travel agent
you know where we stay and he said the
Trump Hotel I was like oh [ __ ] all right
Trump Hotel Donny okay so we [ __ ]
stay there man and I didn't understand I
know that people don't like Donald Trump
but I don't I didn't understand that
they also don't like his buildings
because the [ __ ] jerk-off has put his
name on every building so now when
people hate him they you know his name
is there so they stand in front they do
all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] right like you
know [ __ ] you Donny right outside of the
thing so anyway so we go in there
of course it's [ __ ] incredible it's
[ __ ] beautiful the service was
amazing the food was incredible
everything and there was great like this
is what he's good at this is what he
should have stayed doing this is his
wheelhouse you don't to me this is like
Elvis keep singing the songs dude don't
make the [ __ ] movies so anyways we're
staying there all weekend we had a great
[ __ ] time you know quick walk down to
the the venue right so I say Taniya I go
Nia you know I go you know I believe up
stamp staying in a Trump Hotel she goes
no you're not I'm like yeah I am i added
[ __ ] you know i didn't book it you
know i just i show i worried about the
shows now this is great i don't have to
[ __ ] think about anything
so she's breaking my balls right don't
like is it the greatest hotel ever you
know doing that show you know it's kind
of [ __ ] nice i'm not gonna lie to you
so I actually took a video
of the of the room and all that in the
view I had and everything and she wrote
back to me she goes I got a mitt that
bastard makes it nice hotel so anyways I
I ran into somebody that I knew at the
air at the airport so you know where
were you working we're talking blah blah
blah he's you know somehow where I
stayed came up and I mentioned it to him
so he starts breaking my balls he's like
going you know that guy's not a good
person it's like yeah I agree with that
and he goes you should spend your money
elsewhere I'm like well look he's still
[ __ ] president so like me not staying
there is that somehow not gonna make him
president he's like no he's like oh-ho
you know a horrible [ __ ] person and
yeah yeah yeah and I go so wish should I
stay then look the Hilton's the
Sheridan's like oh they're all good
people aren't they all billionaires like
who the [ __ ] do you think they voted for
like yeah you know I don't know kind of
bugged me a little bit with everybody
having to give everybody a [ __ ]
lecture it's like you're really gonna
sit here as you hold a [ __ ] Apple
laptop computer have you ever read about
them I don't think the ones that had
people leaping to their deaths at their
[ __ ] sweatshop cuz they they they had
it worked so much it didn't he made so
little their lives were so helpful
hopeless they were jumping out of the
factory so they had to [ __ ] put Nets
up around the [ __ ] thing you know and
then they played soothing music and then
they considered possibly giving them
more money which was really the solution
so I mean all the clothes I'm wearing
what I really want to see the people's
lives who have to [ __ ] put it
together we're gonna stop this you know
you gonna give me a lecture as we're
getting on a [ __ ] plane that uses
fuel where do we get the fuel we get it
from the Middle East what the [ __ ]
going on over there how many innocent
people have died over the [ __ ] that
were put in this [ __ ] plane okay
while we're trying to liberate them you
know so I don't know it's just it's a
it's a I honest you know I don't know I
don't like Donald Trump okay mostly just
his racial views is what really you know
that's that's what I really don't like
that guy okay
I didn't [ __ ] vote for the guy all
right my Mateus the guy makes a hell of
a [ __ ] hotel I wish that's what he was
still doing exclusively and I'm sure you
guys are gonna give me [ __ ] and somehow
you know take out your frustration on
him on me the fact that I [ __ ] you
know stayed there but I'm telling you
you know if you're gonna play that
[ __ ] game you gotta you got to do it
straight across the board what are you
gonna you pick and choose because you
know that's another that's like another
like I feel like it's it's it's almost
the way like when you go to when
somebody goes to a comedy show and they
laugh at all the [ __ ] jokes until I
Drive across their front yard then all
of a sudden I didn't do a joke now I'm
making statements and their feelings are
[ __ ] hurt it's like if you really
care to that level going this guy's a
bad [ __ ] person then I would say that
you would really be limiting that you
should be staying at some sort of
mom-and-pop [ __ ] hotel if you can
find it as you then go down and try to
find some organic [ __ ] guy that's not
a corporate farmer you know cuz they've
poisoned the food I mean you start going
down that road or maybe I guess you just
pick your battle I have no idea but I
will tell you this that hotel was so
[ __ ] nice I actually weighed my
wife's getting mad at me I just call I
said Mia are you gonna get mad if I stay
at another one of these and she laughed
she goes yes you [ __ ] [ __ ] so I
said alright fair enough
so whatever I want it done I want it
done like the Titans beaten the Patriots
congratulations on your huge victory in
November you know they should have a
trophy for [ __ ] teams like that and I
can't I'm not picking on lemme picking
on Titan so I just didn't like what Dean
Lewis said though you know you didn't
talk any [ __ ] before the [ __ ] game
and then you [ __ ] win and now you're
gonna run your [ __ ] Yap the [ __ ] out
of here you hate this organ is you know
what it is he said [ __ ] you know he's
[ __ ] mad that he wants to please all
I hear is I still want to play for the
Patriots when he was at the patrons you
know they got a witty way here they got
the whatever they're doing is working
and all of a sudden you get caught up
with a watch to that all of a sudden the
Patriots of [ __ ] [ __ ]
Patriots day at a trump hotel
some of them do anyways anyways
is there a Clinton hotel I could stay at
maybe get back and your peoples good
graces Jesus Christ they got the meat to
Rueben that one Oh bill come on you know
I just feel like you're better than that
okay let's bring people back together
here what the [ __ ] is this story I was
Google News hey how about those broads
man they're starting to play alright I
started to [ __ ] what it again I
watched them play the Toronto game when
I was there in Chicago and I had a
flashback
I played the Chicago theater with Jimmy
noir and Jim Breuer and Dave Attell on
the anti social tour I can't believe it
was seven [ __ ] years ago and I
remember I was in the greenroom at the
end of the show and I was late to the
meet-and-greet cuz I was watching the
[ __ ] Bruins win the Stanley Cup
former Clinton advisor Hillary will run
in 2020 if she ever becomes president
that's gonna be a great 30 for 30 of
course she's gonna run again she feels
it's she thinks it's her job please
Democrats don't [ __ ] oh my god how
many [ __ ] times how many times how
many times you gonna play marty ball can
you get somebody in there alright
there's got to be somebody else you
can't tell me the Democrats are gonna be
dumb enough to hitch their [ __ ] wagon
again how many times how many times do
you put that person under center and you
come away with the loss before you don't
go to your second string quarterback
that's all I'm asking this has got to be
the most politically charged podcast
I've ever done where do I get off not
paying attention
forgetting to submit an absent
ballot telling people who should run for
president where the [ __ ] was that story
I was looking for oh wow the guy was the
voice of the computer in 2001 died do
you have to have it there was a woman
out there was such a big fan of that
that [ __ ] wanted him to talk like
that during sex sorry well the [ __ ] is
his story I was looking for some [ __ ]
guy in Texas broke into a house and bled
out because he cut his arm on the window
all I can think is how nice was the
stuff in the house getting dizzy oh look
at that vase anyways is it time for the
old geez it's time for the advertising
there
oh what a hotel that was Jesus Christ
what a [ __ ] hotel the steam room was
incredible
a lot of these hotels you go to right
other than the fifth in Milwaukee you go
into the steam room and they they always
have it on like we don't want to hurt
anybody level you know Trump doesn't
give a [ __ ] he'll [ __ ] he'll you know
you'll put kids in cages the guy does
not give a [ __ ] you think this team's
not gonna be hot
[ __ ] eucalyptus was like [ __ ] ye
first he was saying ah it's burning my
eyes right there was so much eucalyptus
in there III don't know I felt like you
know when you chew like really like
winter fresh gum or like like minty
[ __ ] gum that's what my eyeballs felt
like there was tremendous what the [ __ ]
am I going here I'm trying I'm trying to
find the advertising alright here we go
oh look who's here everybody old zip
there are job sites that make you want
to that make you wait for the right
candidates to apply to your job
not smart capital letters
you know what's not I'm yelling all the
Capitol's making the lottery the
centerpiece of your retirement plan oh
Jesus
oh man I had friends like that though
what are you doing after high school I'm
just going to work what are you go how
you gonna ahead I'll hit the lottery I'm
gonna hit the [ __ ] lottery kid zip
recruiter going to zip recruiter calm
yeah you know what is smart going to zip
recruit comp slash Bird to hire the
right person old zip doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you it's powerful matching technology
scans thousands of resumes identifies
people with the right skills education
and experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply so you get
qualified candidates fast that's why zip
ok is rayon umber one by employers in
the US this rating comes from the hiring
sites on trust pilot with over one
thousand views there right now I
apologize for being congested I know
it's getting annoying
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zi p r e CR u ITER dot-com / /
that zip recruited comm / / zip the
smartest way to hire oh look who's here
Dollar Shave Club dude dollar shave club
is anything everything you need to feel
and smell your best you never have to go
to this store that's what I do it for
bureau no time just screaming capital
capitalized words in the copy because
evidently they want me to stress it case
you missed it the first time you never
have to go to a store that's because
they deliver everything you need right
to you Dilla and they keep you fully
stocked of what you use so you don't run
out here's how it works Dollar Shave
Club has everything you need to get
ready no matter what you're getting
ready for they have you covered head to
toe for your hair yes
in your face you name it they have it
and they have this new program where
they automatically keep you stocked up
on products you use you determine what
you want and when you want it then it
shows right up to your door from once a
month to once every six months depending
on how filthy you are you [ __ ] animal
plus with their handsome discount the
more you buy the more you save and right
now Dollar Shave Club has a bunch of
status sets you can try for just five
dollars like their oral care kit
after that the restock box ships regular
size products at regular price get your
status set for just five dollars right
now at dollarshaveclub.com slash bar
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash bar all
right how many more - more all right
stamps don't come everybody you know
these days you could practically get
everything on demand like our podcast
listen whatever you want when it's
convenient for you did you know you can
even get postage on demand all you need
is stamps calm stamps calm you can
access all the service at the post
office right from your desk by and print
real US postage for any letter or any
package just click Brit mail and you're
done
stamps calm will even send you a digital
scale you can weigh your letters and
packages and print the exact amount of
postage every time four-week trial
includes postage and a digital scale go
to stamps calm before you do anything
else your kid can eat later click on the
radio and the micro spray do microphone
to the top of the homepage sorry and
type it bar that stamp star comment or
power for reads why did that say for
reads makes me feel like I missed one
alright Oh lastly but not leastly lastly
but not leastly my bookie I adored IRA
my bookie Sharon watching football is
fun but it's more entertaining when you
got a little action or the game huh you
want some action come over here in the
corner go to [ __ ] book each other up
guys you've heard me talking about this
for a week and some of you are still on
the sidelines whether you're an expert
or a rookie
you should be betting that my bookie get
over you put some [ __ ] lead Abel if
you're the kind of guy that likes to bet
a little and win a lot like playing the
numbers on roulette you can create a big
parlay pick three teams to win and if
you hit all three you could turn a
hundred dollars into 600 if you don't
you're gonna lose a little north of a
hundred dollars just to let you know
there's there's so much to bet on
college basketball and football NBA NHL
custom props even eSports you can better
video games you name it
my bookie how you doing already is one
of the best is the one bet I know you'll
be happy with all year I recommend these
guys because they pay me to say my
bookie are you doing has been in
business for years they've got great
online reviews and their mobile site is
easy to use sign up this week at my
bookie and my bookie will give you a a
50% deposit bonus to jumpstart your
bankroll it's a great way to bank even
more money when you win also make sure
to follow at my bet my bookie on Twitter
they personally respond to every mention
India not to mention that they give
they've given away more than ten
thousand dollars in free money to their
followers this football season you'll be
the first to know as soon as the odds
and props are posted whatever props are
don't miss out on one of the best weeks
to bet on sports this year log on to my
bookie right now use promo code promo
code there to get I guess that's
supposed to be BRR I don't have the
[ __ ] promo code then you get 50 50
percent deposit bonus that's promo
current code Joe Rogan how about that
you play you win you get paid [ __ ] I
could give you a promo code I'll [ __ ] it
pass it on to one of the biggest
sweethearts of this [ __ ] business you
know something like you know these
[ __ ] fires out here a couple of you
know good friends of mine had to flee
that [ __ ] so fortunately for last I
heard their houses are alright but good
lord
but those winds whipping around like
those [ __ ] literally fire tornadoes I
mean it's just like it's just insane but
you know we choose to live out here who
is the [ __ ] [ __ ] that decided to
put the entertainment business out here
ah you know what you can't even [ __ ]
about the fires out here
that's how nice the weather is it's just
one of those things God's never gonna
let you chill okay oh you liking this
you liking this here's here's a [ __ ]
fire tornado just to keep you honest
just to remind you not to be a [ __ ]
anyways I am so [ __ ] psyched to be
home
I am NOT doing [ __ ] I'm really go for
the first time i life try and rest up
get some sleep I love the holiday season
dooby dooby doo its googly pop look
who's here it's your [ __ ] Papa's been
on the road you remember me I look like
a stranger I been gone so [ __ ] long
why do you cry when you see me cause I'm
absentee oh yeah see I don't I don't
want to be that guy I'm completely
changing the way I work and all of that
type of [ __ ] so thank God for FaceTime
but I came home and my daughter was just
waking up for a nap and I poked my head
in it she gave me a big smile and you
know changed her and all that type of
stuff and she was laying on the changing
table and she reached up and she gave me
like I swear to God like 12 hugs in a
row was playing with my beard and just
looking at me I could see in her eyes
she legitimately missed me and it's just
like this no there's no [ __ ] way that
I'm gonna you know I'm witness bummin oh
I'm gonna start working smart because I
get I get it I think I really get it now
I do I'm not arguing with my wife she
gives me the honey-do list
I just [ __ ] do it cuz I'll tell you
that's still
the only way you're gonna be happy and
your your marriage truly happy is if you
just do every [ __ ] thing they want
you to do I tell you do that that you
women are so easy to get along with all
right
so by next you know I got like a quick
little like a three four-day run I'm
doing a benefit back east and I'm
promoting season 3 of f is for family
I'm gonna be doing Seth my a old friend
of mine from back in the day I actually
got to know him way back when I was on
Breaking Bad and we were both huge fans
of the show we would [ __ ] geek out
Senate each other emails try to figure
out where the show was gonna go next and
it was such a great show
I was actually honored for a couple
episodes in yeah I couldn't even figure
out where I was gonna go but whatever so
I'll be very excited to to out get on
that show if it listens to this podcast
I imagine will give me [ __ ] for staying
at the Trump Chicago I would have stayed
at the Obama but he you know he doesn't
[ __ ] it up but you know does he go to
[ __ ] ice creeps did so I could be you
know it's not partisan what would that
be if I actually stated at Trump Hotel
and ate it Obama's ice cream stand then
when I truly be independent or I be
called a centrist and who made that ice
cream how many cows had to die to make
that ice cream well Bill they don't die
they milk them well you know what I
guess I don't know what I'm talking
about anyways uh when in Thailand Talon
bill went in Tallinn Estonia try the
pancakes in compressor just do it
alright well you're like Nike there's
another green Oh everybody likes their
Jordans right I do what are you get to
Jordan chill you're doing [ __ ] trees
go to their [ __ ] factory Jesus Christ
I mean I don't understand how they get
they just [ __ ] get away with all of
that [ __ ] that you can just treat people
like that and why don't you [ __ ] you
know fly commercial
you can bump up the price of the
sneakers a little bit back the day when
I was a kid like [ __ ] was made here and
it wasn't ridiculously expensive because
they was going hey you want us to make
[ __ ] over here okay it's gonna be nine
million dollars for some Shuster eggs
it's like that's because you don't want
to take any money out of your pocket you
can't sorry all right there should be a
global union but you'll never be able to
do you'll never be able to get that done
Tallinn Estonia here we go
a global union of just regular people
against these [ __ ] rich cuts that
should be the new world order all right
yeah but then you know yeah you know the
thing is you can't have one side either
side having too much power because back
in the day when unions were really
powerful here let me look what they
didn't take advantage of that they
weren't guilty of kind of driving some
of these factories like I can't deal
with these [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I've
dealt with the Union [ __ ] houses I
tried to shoot specials and in these
places they gouge the [ __ ] out of you
you show up and then like mandatory
there's got to be 20 [ __ ] [ __ ]
people to put a mic stand in a stool on
a stage because that's how many people
we need when a Dave Matthews shows up
you know when they bring in Carter both
for its [ __ ] 900 piece drum set and
I'm showing up you know microphone mic
state of the stolid I got to have
[ __ ] four four guys got to be up
there you got to pay for [ __ ] guys
and everything goes through the goddamn
roof so maybe corporations aren't bad
maybe they're just human beings with too
much freedom I think that's what it is
what do you get too much freedom you act
like a [ __ ] white people
all right talent Wikipedia guilty as
charged
all right Travel Guide well let's check
out the weather here Oh [ __ ] cold
Tallinn Estonia weather oh my god oh
these pictures this is 40 degrees
raining that's not bad all right images
oh my god I am not showing any of these
pictures to my wife
well I know this has to be the
picturesque downtown area but still what
a downtown it is oh my god there's how
much I love my wife when I go to places
like this I actually feel guilt oh my
god it's [ __ ] beautiful I bet they'll
have great [ __ ] stories to Estonia
World War two this is all you do where
were you guys what side of the fence
World War two Oh what did they side with
you understand those countries the
decision they had to make do I go with
Stalin or I go with [ __ ] Hitler to
the biggest [ __ ] mass murdering
lunatics of all time you know sometimes
you just not left with a good [ __ ]
choice like last election sometimes it's
2:00 a.m. at a bar you just got to pick
some what although I don't know if you
know you still have to go Stalin you
don't have me just I mean Hitler what
Hitler was these Hitler is that dude
he's the [ __ ] Freddie Mercury of mass
murderers you know the end like an 12
octave evil range you know a lot of
waste Olli he kind of looks like Tom
Selleck a little bit right it looks just
a little beady-eyed [ __ ] anyways
before the outbreak of the Second World
War Germany and the Soviet Union signed
the german-soviet non-aggression pact
yeah and some little douche [ __ ] with
a dustpan sweeper of a mustache he broke
that didn't he
concerning the partition that's got to
be one of the most [ __ ] up things ever
that he actually thought he was gonna
beat Russia that little ass [ __ ]
country was gonna go in there I mean you
know they were coming over there with
their [ __ ] Mercedes Benz and Porsche
[ __ ] machine guns and planes and tanks
I mean you could see why the Republic of
Estonia declared neutrality in the war
but fell under the Soviet sphere
of influence due to oh my god the
molotov-ribbentrop pact you know it's
funny if you watch jeopardy somebody
will
what is the molotov-ribbentrop pact
it only gets 50 points if I knowing that
so they end up being occupied by the
Soviet Union in 1940 mass political
arrests so they still got [ __ ]
deportations and executions followed
know Jesus and people in stonee Allah
but what about the molotov-ribbentrop
pact I have a little flyer here you want
to look at it Jesus Christ whatever you
read this [ __ ] you just realize how
[ __ ] lucky you are to be living
wherever the hell you live and guys this
is if there's not [ __ ] like this going
on I love the guy from Estonia he's got
a hey listen man I just told you to get
some [ __ ] pancakes I didn't tell you
to go that that deep well let's look it
up here compressor Estonia style it back
here compress our pancakes there's
enough mercedes beds it's just like
German pancakes oh [ __ ] okay I'm in well
it looks like and fluffy it's got a
pound of butter on it I don't know how
that is in the metric system it's like a
caramelized [ __ ] piece of banana
alright I'm there Jesus Christ I'd
better start the only way it sucks about
this tour is I'm only I'm just doing one
night it's the whole way like I'm gonna
miss so much [ __ ] I'm just gonna kind of
drive by it but you know I got a kid now
so ok Poland all right so I'm getting
pancakes at compressor in Estonia Poland
hey bald-headed [ __ ] this is from around
the world you know when you're
follically challenged like myself you
really don't feel like you just you're
just a man without a country me and my
buddy a huge fans living in
: I can't [ __ ] wait to go there so I
bet this woman a long time ago when I
was on the road and I think I was an
eighth well we started talking as that
flight was delayed and she said she was
from Poland I was sad did stand up she
goes yeah they got clubs over there and
I was like she told me how you wanted to
actually a long row by geographies bad
now she was telling me that they have
all this pull it pull it pull lid bump
up up up up what body of water is that
right is it the Baltic Sea Poland see
geography applaud Baltic Sea look at old
Billy [ __ ] globe head the Baltic Sea
yes there was some towns along there she
was like oh that's what you want to play
but I'm not I'm gonna die I think I'm
being Warsaw you know right there Fred
right the middle of the country I
believe anybody nobody a huge fans of
Poland and we hear you are coming to a
city in this [ __ ] country I don't
[ __ ] tell me that it would be nice if
we knew when the dates were so we could
so we know if we could make it one of
the chances you could tell us all the
best and go [ __ ] yourself there be it's
all being announced in a week it was all
supposed to be announced at the same
time but Germany was all like oh we need
to announce it now right my age it was
like why do you feel you neither what
else is no talk do what Jackie makes it
right German talking to the Jew so he
ended up backing down he's like all
right you [ __ ] loaded texting
[Music]
announced it when you want to and they
did it it went great so the tickets got
sold over there anyways best friends
it'll be all be announced in a week all
right all right best friends with best
friend's wife from a lady
oh hello Billy Baldwin I get it I get it
once again making me feel bad about my
mood shaped head
recently I've been posting pictures and
videos of my Instagram that are
dot-dot-dot not [ __ ] alright so right
there they're of a risque okay hang on
say I got I gotta clear my nose here
hallo second alright this is just one of
these things where if I lay down my nose
just [ __ ] just blocks up but if I'm a
second I stand up it's fine I don't
understand it
anyways alright so you're posting these
pictures that are not [ __ ] but I
wouldn't show my parents either well
alright okay there is there's a window
in there there's a window in there cuz
they're gonna be like you give your
dresses - sure
come on honey what are you doing you're
killing your father right I'm 26 years
old and I've been feeling very confident
about myself and my body good for you
I'm singing I wish I felt the same way
about my head how can i when everybody
makes fun of it I like my head and I
don't care what I believe Christina
Aguilera said it best when she said I am
beautiful and I believe her [ __ ] was as
bald as the top of my head judging by
some of her outfits you know what I mean
I mean the skirts were so slow the hair
would be hanging out underneath right Oh
bill like what why do you have to be so
crass cuz I'm not funny you know when
you're not funny you go right to the
genitals I mean it's the 20 oldest
oldest is one of the oldest things in
comedy I'm 26 years old and be feeling
good about my body but I'm single with
no boyfriend or even dating well I have
a good time go buy a [ __ ] suitcase
full of condoms and jump on it oh I'm
sorry
anyways my friend okay anyways my friend
since I was 16 has told me that his wife
has been uncomfortable with us talking
because she's seen my pictures
well yeah you sound like you're in the
prime of your life
you're obviously crushing it
she told him she feels insecure and sees
my pictures even before he does he's
expressed that he may not be my friend
anymore because of this while he's doing
the right thing you know happy wife
happy life
hey she ain't happy nobody's gonna be
happy why doesn't he just unfun follow
you can you just do that you guys could
be friends
in a different way I don't know it's
weird
that's all weird I get where his wife's
coming from she's you know my wife was
sudden somebody you know and he's he's
[ __ ] posted banana hammock pup
pictures I don't feel like I'm gonna be
too comfortable with that right swing
low Sweet Chariot sorry she told me she
feels insecure and sees my pictures even
before he does he is expressed that he
may not be friends anymore because of
this sorry I had to reread that again
but I know a lot of you guys watch
reality shows and they always come back
and show you what you just saw and this
is not the first time I've been blocked
by male friends because now this is when
we need Nia because their female
counterparts our social media is
stalking me and claiming I'm trying to
get their man I've been told to tone
down my posts are not right how I feel
because the girls take it personally and
take it out of my friends now on some
level you know you got to know what
you're doing
alright here's that this is the deal
okay because men are weak women are
[ __ ] gorgeous there are certain rules
that you do have to follow alright and
for you to be as beautiful as you are
and feeling as confident as you are
about your body it posted those pictures
nothing wrong with that but when you
start being friends with all these guys
that are in relationships like you're
single go be friends with guys that
aren't in relationships it's a it's a
tough thing it's a tough thing it's not
your fault you're pretty and you feel
like [ __ ] showing it off a little bit
not too [ __ ] not too [ __ ] dad
appreciate this anyways I've been told
to tone it down on to or not to rate I
feel uh are these my real friends or do
girls have legit reasons to be upset
yours truly a huge fan and love to Nia
and the baby [ __ ] I might have to do an
epilogue on this and get Nia you know
what I'm gonna happen I'm gonna answer
this and on Thursday Nia will give her
answer look at that teasing the next
episode like a pro listen if you're if
you're not passively aggressively you
know being a dick tease just because you
like that attention and you're just
legitimately just you know like how you
look and saying how you feel then then I
don't think you're wrong but I don't
think they're wrong either you know what
I mean I don't know how it works with
women but when a woman is more
attractive or makes another woman feel
less attractive and it's talking to them
their guy yeah that's gonna be a guys
get like that right some guy comes up
you know he's all [ __ ] jacked
he's got pigment he's got hair I mean
how am I gonna feel you know you don't
think I'm gonna truck and puff up my
little freckled [ __ ] chest you know
trying to recite some line from a
[ __ ] Sylvester Stallone movie huh
hey are you like Debbie Apple so
whatever the [ __ ] it is just combine
movies yeah that this is what I would do
I would just say I would respect the
women in these relationships and what
you need to do is you need to find some
guys that are single to follow you all
right knowing what comes with that like
oh my god you all right like that's
what's your going to be getting you know
but I wouldn't worry about it either
great problems to have I mean you could
be [ __ ] ugly living under a bridge
crying every Friday and Saturday night
because the wants to go near you so you
know it's nice to have a lot of
Sudha's III was you I would just I would
I would expand my friends circle alright
and also you know what didn't you say
that you weren't posting like that and
then recently I've been posting pictures
of videos I mean yeah okay yeah so
everything was cool until you started
doing that so that's what changed see
sometimes when you change as a person
you you lose a few friends so that's
this what I would say you're not
historically been doing this you know I
don't know what you had like your
[ __ ] I sell real estate headshot on
there the family values one and now
you're out there like whoa what the [ __ ]
I'm only gonna be young once we're gonna
go out and have a good time that all of
a sudden these people locked out or
relationships yeah yeah you could have a
problem you get have a problem so I
don't necessarily think you're doing
anything wrong I just think that if
that's the way you're gonna be you can't
be around guys that are in relationships
and in fairness to them you're gonna be
causing them to get into a lot of
goddamn arguments alright
and I guarantee you at least one of them
is thinking about one of your pictures
when he bends his [ __ ] girl over I'm
just telling you okay as a guy that's
what's happening and the woman knows it
especially when they mutter your name
what did you say I said we should be
sharing more stuff what a share in my
life with you
a husband having emotional affair while
we are living in Tokyo hey Billy Boat
act
how do you know boat act India that's a
[ __ ] inside joke there you [ __ ]
boat act that's an insult to a comedian
things have been difficult with my
husband and I since we moved to Tokyo
from the US I went through his phone to
find him messaging his new teammate all
day not just about work stuff either I
don't know if it would be flirting but
it made me uncomfortable there are
things he's messaging her before he even
tells me yet none of the
cool I confronted him but he swears to
me he would never do something like that
to me what should I do next it's hard to
not want to go through his phone I
wonder what they're up to at work thank
you so much and go [ __ ] yourself I would
just tell him that because of his
[ __ ] behavior you now have urges to
go through his phone alright would you
be comfortable if I was texting a guy
that I worked with that much if I was
telling him personal stuff about myself
before I told you it's not [ __ ] cool
that's not cool on any [ __ ] level and
you're 100% right what you do about it I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what the move is there I don't know you
got it yeah you got a [ __ ] at Jesus
Christ ah relationships aren't they fun
all this technology all the new [ __ ]
ways this is all there's so many [ __ ]
people out there men and women who we
not do with the [ __ ] that they would be
doing posting [ __ ] sexy pictures of
yourself that the whole [ __ ] world
can see do you really so [ __ ] nuts
that is that you can do that now there's
somebody can actually in their house
look at these sexy photos of you in a
room jerking their dick to it and then
their wife walks in what are you doing
uh it's just putting on lotion yeah I
think the way human beings are
interacting right now we were never
meant to interact this way it is like
the level of voyeurism that is just
[ __ ] mainstream it's not healthy all
right and I'm not I'm not wagging my
finger at anybody here I mean I stated
at Rupp hotel Who am I to tell anybody
anything anyways Tom Cruise is at it
again
all right yo bill read this on Twitter
read this on Twitter wanted to hear your
reaction you think Tommy Boy can pull it
off it's Tom Cruise whatever you gonna
say yes he can you [ __ ] pull it off I
know you're not a fighter pilot but I
figure you're in the aviation world and
understand
stuff okay that's a major I have a
private pilot's license and I have under
200 hours but I'll tell you I'm a hell
of a pilot a lot of time I have okay
that bought that boy Tommy Cruise is at
it again
the actor who insists on doing his own
stunts might be taking things even
further on for Top Gun - aka Top Gun
maverick this is this is a rumor for now
because it comes from an anonymous
source over at the Daily Mail in other
words it never happened but I'll
continue reading but Cruz apparently
wants to really fly a fighter jet in the
movie not just pretend if this is true
will know about it soon because Cruz is
never shy about publicly about publicity
regarding his crazy ass stunts I
certainly wouldn't be surprised that
this turned out to be the real deal
though no it's not publicity he's
selling the movie and if he [ __ ] flew
a helicopter nose down into a goddamn
ravine yeah they're gonna talk about it
yeah that's not true there's no way
that's [ __ ] true okay I actually did
a little research on this question and
f-35 costs just south of a hundred
million dollars you're not gonna stick a
[ __ ] actor in there now they might if
he could fly two people in it which I
don't know they might put him up there
with the [ __ ] instructor okay and let
him fly the [ __ ] thing around and
they could do it that way and then just
digitally remove that guy from the
[ __ ] the the shot or whatever I don't
know just Tom Cruise if anybody's gonna
do it I would imagine it would be him
but there's no [ __ ] way they're gonna
let him fly one solo I mean that's
probably the entire budget of the
[ __ ] movie if he crashes that thing
he's got a parachute out I don't know
yeah I would I would say yeah there's no
way he's gonna fly too low but I think
there's a good chance that he could you
know fly it around if if there was
somebody else up there with them which
would I would think just be just taking
the stick you know right I can't imagine
how small the movements are in that
thing before your inverted you know
terrified it would be like okay bill you
have controls I have controls you have
controls right and then you [ __ ] III
would move that thing well a [ __ ]
[ __ ] hair just to seek worried that I
would be like totally do you understand
like also like if you look at the
training of that but God knows he's
gonna do it like when you've just I
don't even know at what speed anytime
you do those maneuvers like they have to
like tighten up their entire [ __ ]
insides or their whole body to keep the
blood from going down to their feet and
then passing out while they're flying
there's this they have a suit that like
compresses it and like I mean I don't
know anything about it but like what
what they're doing is is just completely
at like you know you just look at f1
racing the amount of G's where they're
coming down the straightaway when just
hitting the brakes and then making that
turn like their neck muscles are
literally off the [ __ ] chains from
just being able to hold it up right now
I know they have that device in us so
they can kind of lean against it but
back in the day like back in the day
those old-school stock car drivers like
Dale Earnhardt if you ever went to
[ __ ] try to choke that guy to death
he could just sit there staring at you
would he drank a beer as you squeezed
with all you but be like trying to choke
out a [ __ ] Louisville Slugger and
those guys are just going to you know
200 miles an hour I can't imagine you
know is every Mach a speed of sound is
that what it is Mach 1 is the speed of
sound is that or is it a thousand miles
an hour I can't even [ __ ] remember
but those planes can basically do [ __ ]
that the human body can't even [ __ ]
handle at this point
if it wasn't Tom Cruise if it wasn't Tom
Cruise I would be confident to say that
they won't let him do it but it is Tom
Cruise it is part of his brand and
that's how it works out here your brand
I'm gonna say he's gonna go up with an
instructor and they're gonna be flying
slow and he's gonna do some [ __ ] that's
what I want that's what I'm gonna guess
he's gonna learn how to invert it and
stuff like that and this guy's going to
be he's going to be on with him
in other words he's also on the [ __ ]
controls and I don't know I mean Jesus
quiet you talking about a guy that hung
onto the side of a [ __ ] plane while
it took off flew the pattern and came
back around and landed I mean I wouldn't
put anything past that guy you know and
I got all the respect in the world for
him because all I do was member memorize
my lines and be like I stopped on that
piece of tape and then I say it okay
that's the level of work that I put into
it I'm kidding actually think of a
decent actor alright then you can see it
you know right now in New York in LA
with the limited release of the
frontrunner starring Hugh Jackman who
may or may not be a guest on this
podcast later on this week we shall see
we shall see all Billy a-list huh
that'd be the biggest [ __ ] guest they
have a god I think be right up to here
with all of them the biggest people I
forgot another spot okay I have so few
guests I can't [ __ ] remember Chris
Layton was a huge one drama for Stevie
Ray Vaughn telling all those Stevie
[ __ ] stories that was a big one but
anyways the front runner will be have a
nationwide release I believe later on
this week and why don't you swing by and
check it out it's a great movie it's a
Gary Hart story all right Hugh Grant
Vera Farmiga directed by Jason Reitman
in old freckles don't blink you'll miss
me alright have a great couple of days
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll check it out
yeah on Thursday
you